alors soyez là où la bienvenue à votre
tam tam canada du 30 octobre
aujourd'hui du vaudou aux fantômes en
passant par là lwin dans cette émission
du 30 octobre la fête d'halloween au
canada bien sûr est à l'honneur non on
en profite aussi pour vous parler des
masques du voodoo du mauvais sort des
cimetières une émission à faire glacer
le sang et on espère que ça va on va
jeter un sort comme ça non seulement sur
les canadiens qui ils sont allés cote en
ce moment mais aussi sur le monde entier
puisque après tout nous sommes radio
canada international
là on vient de se tourner vers la caméra
on y est de se distancer du microphone
pour faire beau bonjour à nos amis sur
facebook live cette émission et prix
enregistrée vendredi
je vous dis pas à calar ça reste un
secret mais c'est diffusé comme ça en
direct mais en retard sur crédit si
c'est ça le dimanche mais la formule
radiophonique de cette émission est
diffusée dimanche et la formule le
facebook library en raccourci c'est le
vendredi et s'est exprimé il faut
l'identifier qui est sept suspects au
micro c'est paloma martinez bonjour
parle j'ai fait ça va ça va très bien
ici stéphane parent avant qu'on commence
cette expérience du facebook live et de
ce total canada du 30 août évidemment
octobre 30 tout quand j'assiste dit
quelque chose d'aussi faible du dit
donald et au nahd aux états unis oui
parce que vous savez au mexique on a
cette tradition de la piñata on frappe
sur tout mais on fera tour sur tout ce
qu'on peut donc qu'un certain de
s'exprimer de façon non violente mais
amusante on crée des piñata puis on
dégage toute notre énergie sur la piñata
bill est maintenant la nouvelle
tradition mexique c'est la piñata donald
trump
donc les gens après les commentaires de
monsieur trompe de cannes c'est la
république est à l'arrêt père à la
présidence américaine
le mexicain 70 ans il faut faire une
piñata avec le visage ou le corps de
monsieur 38 ans va sortir le méchant je
cherche ça me fâche tout je sais qu'on a
fait on était vent lors le sondage gogo
cette année 2005 qu'est-ce qui lé plus
populaires du côté des masques chez le
jeune canadien
attendez doute dixième position
tyrannosaure 9
un ange pour ce dragon en huitième
position 7 et les loups garous supergirl
en 5 ça c'est une série américaine finit
au canada bien sûr tout est fini aucun
doute à ce jour si ça coûte très cher
iron man en quatrième position comme
masque troisième tube aka évidemment de
star wars i am yoda ah oui la photo est
là va falloir expliquer à tout le monde
à l'extérieur du canada sait qu est ce
qu elle cette invention en première
position au niveau des masques et des
costumes chez les jeunes enfants
la pâte patrouille
connaissez vous ça vous avez monté que
notre technicien déjà enfant il connaît
ça c'est sûr c'est le propre touche
pense qu on allait
c'est ça la version francophone la
princesse est pas de trop et le pire en
espagne en tout cas ça c'est une série
qui est une série télévisée canadienne
qui a beaucoup de succès non seulement
ici au canada mais aussi en france à lui
et coûte présentement ce très très
populaire là bas
écoutez on diverge en divers notre
direction c'est cela c'est de parler de
la question la semaine prochaine pas de
ce qui se passe cette semaine on a tout
à fait toujours de l'avant
alors voici une nouvelle question je
vous donne l'ordre d'exécution alesi on
vous écoute
qu'aimeriez-vous dire aux électeurs
américains qui s'apprêtent à élire leur
nouveau président aux précédentes ce
mardi 8 novembre
bonne chance bonne chance pour votre
wiimote votre participation on aimerait
savoir ce que vous diriez à nos voisins
du sud ont acquis c'est l'art de l'heure
de décider
dites-leur je ne joue pas vous pouvez
donc être sur facebook et sur notre site
web
peu importe où vous allez dans sur notre
site web vous voyez un formulaire à
remplir remplissez on va finir par
savoir que vous répondez à notre
question du jour on va vouloir appeler à
la fin de l'émission pour ne pas que
vous l'oubliez beaucoup été question
dans les rapports avec nos auditeurs
puisque tu aimes tu aimes canada
maintenant la formule c'est
l'interaction pas seulement sur facebook
mais avec l'ensemble de la francophonie
mondiale
c'est notre mission et on s'est
intéressé beaucoup cette semaine au
courrier qu'on a reçues de nos auditeurs
en belgique parce que la belgique et le
canada était au sein de l'action cette
semaine
tout tournait autour de cet accord de
libre-échange canada-union européenne
puis saviez ce petit groupe
d'irréductibles gaulois pas tout à fait
où allons nous en belgique qui disaient
non non non non non non à 500 millions
de personnes à travers donc l'union
européenne et le canada finalement il ya
eu entente mais on a reçu beaucoup de
courrier d'abord il ya un jeune plein
jeunes un jeune courrier philippe
olivier qu'est-ce qu'il dit exactement
c'est à cette entente ses tantes et les
autres photos croire faut-il être à ce
point idiot pour pour croire que ça
puisse apporter quelque chose de bon
citoyen ça se dit en interne à tous
avait dit a dit diouf comme ça c'est des
choses qui disent les gens sur internet
philippe olivier c'est ce qu'il dit et
de ce traité sont faits pour que les
industriels mettent la main sur tous les
marchés au détriment de ses acquis
sociaux après avoir mis le peuple en
esclavage financiers et monétaires
administratifs et législatifs
après avoir volé au peuple leurs droits
nationaux dans une europe financière à
des riffs kafkaïenne c'est pas fini il
n'y a pas encore de point la france
après avoir dépossédé les peuples de
leur culture et de leurs spécificités
pour les ramener à une norme basse ils
veulent maintenant faire la loi chez les
autres le peuple canadien et européen en
tout à perdre et rien à gagner dans
cette traité hypocrite mensongers et
sens utilité réelle sinon pour
l'industrie des banquiers c'est notre
rôle comme à john radiodiffuseur public
que d'équilibrer les propos à l'antenne
alors pour une réaction de gérard picard
en france en réponse à philippe olivier
qui dit merci les wallons et les autres
les gouvernements sont complices des
grands groupes car seulement un petit
étang sur 28 a pu réduire en déduire que
les 27 autres ont indiqué et ce n'est
pas la meilleure façon de faire croire
aux citoyens que les politiques dont les
politiciens sont là pour nous protéger
ils ne voient que leur petit intérêt je
vois moi je parlerais de gros intérêts
quand même vivement
il ajoute y at-il au sein de
l'administration canadienne de la part
des hommes politiques
une notion de service public autrement
dit est-ce qu'il ya des gens honnêtes
parmi vos policiers et on va l'appeler
au téléphone je pense que c'est prévu
dans une couple d'heures donc peut-être
que dans une couple de semaines on va
pouvoir avancer cet échange avec lui
juste vous dire
bientôt on a reçu d'autres courriers
monde est pressé par le temps on a une
auditrice en belgique qui nous a appelés
c'est notre grand maman la grand moment
de tous ceux qui voudraient avoir une
grand maman
la voici la voilà il s'agit dit rehn
elle nous a contactés puisqu'elle tient
à nous parler de son grand père qui a
été le héros de la première guerre
mondiale et comment s'approche du 11
novembre jour du souvenir on s'est dit
oui il faut absolument lui parler c'est
fait mais elle voulait ajouter des
documents donc elle nous appelle pour
dire que ça s'en vient par la poste
voici ce que ça donne je sais que vous
êtes quoi que ce soit qui vous manquent
n'hésitez pas à me contacter ce
correctif téléphone et je vous donnerai
des données encore des compliments donc
ses finances on veut pas de contenu est
ce qu'elle voulait dire c'est des
compléments d'information les continents
on a déjà beaucoup
oh non mais on essaie même les
compliments s'il veut nous envoyer des
documents n'est pas des documents des
compliments
faites-le ce que vous voulez notre
bureau téléphone pour nous appeler comme
cette auditrice en belgique s'agit du
temps dérangeait pas mieux nettement
cédé 4 5 9 7 7 094 famille lunettes
j'arrive pas
adresse électronique du courrier
électronique nous avons passé un
commercial rci med point c est bien
gentil mais un coup de main comme ça
pour pouvoir voir quoi que ce soit alors
je ne suis pas capable de suivre notre
plan de match aujourd'hui où je sais que
notre plan de match inclus oui de parler
des quelques deux d'un coup de coeur
vous avez vu cette semaine d'une jeune
femme qui s'exprime en anglais et vous
avez parlé cette femme là vous avez fait
la traduction de ce qu'elle avait à dire
et vous vous avez été touché par son
témoignage
si tu as touché par son témoignage elle
s'appelle ruia chams
orolia est arrivé au canada il y a 6 ans
à peu près et puis elle est partie de
son pays natal afghanistan dans ce
moment très difficile pour elle parce
qu'elle venait de perdre son père qui a
été assassiné par le talibans et il
était policier me défendrai beaucoup le
droit de femmes donc et puis le défendez
les droits de ses filles et à s'éduquer
denrées yaël s'éduquer puis elle donnait
aussi des cours d'anglais des cultures
et des lectures aux femmes aux femmes
âgées donc ruia et du pas dû partir de
son pays
rapidement et elle est arrivée au canada
parce que les tarifs comme réfugiés ou
mais elle a été aidée par un journaliste
un journaliste du globe and mail qui
avait fait un reportage sur elle et sur
son père en afghanistan avant qu'elles
viennent ici donc c'est intéressant
parce qu'elle est venue faire des études
finir ses études secondaires puis
ensuite elle est maintenant étudiante à
l'université d'ottawa point vue très
très joyeux oui il aime la vie et même
sans sa vie maintenant
hélas beaucoup de travail à faire on les
écoute on eu pendant quelques instants
si vous voulez entendre l'intégrale de
cette entrevue car il est pas le mans
vous allez bien sûr sur la page tam tam
tam tam canada s'est inscrite sous
jeunes hyper viennent en écoute durant
la vie une façon de presse optimiste
depuis que je suis ici au canada j'ai
reçu un grand appui de la part de
beaucoup de monde je ne remercierai
jamais ça
c'est la gentillesse de ces étrangers
envers moi aujourd'hui ces personnes
sont devenus ma famille parce que son
rendu possible ma vie c'était difficile
lorsque je suis arrivé au canada car
c'était un plein hiver et parce que je
ne savais rien de la culture canadienne
ni du climat ni déjà dans mon cours de
civisme en afghanistan on m'avait appris
un peu sur la politique canadienne sans
plus au début de mes études ici j'ai eu
des défis académique importuns mais
quand je vois mon avenir à partir d'où
je suis aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
qu'un rêve devenu réalité pour moi
spécialement le fait que j'ai pu saler à
l'université c'est la vie que j'ai
toujours rêvé
non seulement pour moi mais ceci pour
dit les filles et pour toutes les
personnes depuis quand
voilà la question des réfugiés la
question des migrations et centrale aux
activités radio canada international
bien sûr vous entendez des choses ils
disparaissent un peu comme à la maison
où sa tombe derrière les meubles vous
saviez pas que possédiez telle affaire
quel bijou un incroyable et on découvre
quelques bon des fois deux trois quatre
ans plus tard qu'il ya encore un morceau
de pizza qui est caché en dessous non
c'est pas tout à fait ça là vous
comprendrez bien qu'un site internet
comme radio canada international est un
peu comme ça une bonne pizza mais canada
non pas du tout mais c'est ainsi merci
de me venir en aide
alors votre site est vraiment un endroit
où les internautes vont chercher
beaucoup plus que dans d'autres sites
des histoires pas ancien les des
histoires qui ont encore une une reverb
il ya de résonance encore exactement
alors nous on s'est dit à tam tam canada
non seulement vous offre ce qui améliore
ce qu'on a fait cette semaine comme ce
que vous venez d'entendre mais aussi on
vous oblige à faire un voyage dans le
passé qu'avec nous d'une machine à
remonter le temps quand même alors non
la déposer des hyperliens sur notre page
tomtom canada et notamment il ya une
histoire de fabricants de masques du
québec qui est de f mia et à traquer un
présumé voleur de banque
pas de pizza mais deux
des marques et puis c'est amusant mais
toutes un lien avec l'halloween vous
fichez place exactement les autres liens
avec l'halloween les phobies de quoi
avez vous peur de quoi avez-vous par
stéphane de rater mon rendez vous
facebook là tout va bien
ouais vous ça aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de problème
troisièmement troisiè me permets qu'on a
déposé sur nos pages web à tam tam
canada est-ce que la sorcellerie existe
au canada est elle légale
on va répondre tout de suite pour les
non ce n'est pas je crois que non mais
alors dans okami avez vous été élevée
comme la mienne
maintenant je rends hommage parce que
j'ai des antécédents amérindiens et il
ya beaucoup d'histoires amérindiennes et
beaucoup de drôles d'histoires
amérindienne où il ya des beaucoup de
ceux de l'esprit si on veut il ya des
chamans exactement donc alors vous dites
non louis sako mais comme elle est super
bien pour que les gens puissent aller
voir ça donc je cherchais sorcellerie
sur rci net.com et puis tout vous salle
est tombé sur cette belle histoire voilà
on va vous conseiller une chose ne fait
pas une petite annonce dans les journaux
en disant expert en sorcellerie
écrivez moi non c'est ça c'est considéré
comme étant illégal vous pouvez pas
prétendre être un sorcier puisque
d'après la loi
ça n'existe pas mais voici un extrait
concernant une autre vue qu'on a fait
avec un autre nom un auditeur les
auditeurs qui joue un rôle central dans
nos émissions
récemment quelques temps ils s'appuient
il s'agit de coisy woods a et qui lui
nous parle de la réalité de la
sorcellerie en afrique il a été témoin
de certaines choses il habite le togo
voilà le passé 1 go de données qui
pratique et cela lui légèrement dans nos
villages on en trouve aujourd'hui sa
mêlée à la magie à la magie noire du coc
et voilà donc il ya de petits groupes
qui se crée
les jeunes sont là y sont désolés
il n'y a pas de gloire ce qui est
franchement de trouver des emplois ils
sont obligés de partir des petits
groupes donc on doit leur fait et
initiation par exemple il avoue recevoir
ce qu'on appelle beaucoup de cette
initiation il commence des paroles ça
s'en rend compte et du coup ils
deviennent vraiment aidé à des pneus et
c'est triste et honteux parce que c'est
des énergies je suis né d'un père
récemment et mon papa m'ont répété
féticheur et un deal cette
traditionnelle
donc du coup - servent aussi de se
signer ce qui fait que je vois des
suisses des gens sujet rouleau le matin
tu vois des poudre noire devant capote
dépôt de quoi [ __ ] des poudres tournoi
de couleur noire poudre noire d'accord
s'être appliqué localement avec des
mélanges et avec des animaux exemple
prendre le coeur d'un signe de la tête
lisa et déjà on mélange pas mal de
choses avec des herbes aux colons
schiste dans la forêt et qu'on les chais
de travail du cuir du sud viennent de
puccini en effet de mettre dans une note
en bas sinon granada canaries voilà donc
transforme ça pour que ça devienne
poudre est en france et on les prendrait
de la même manière qu'on guérit cd cd
ses passes décisives c'est de la même
manière qu'on fabrique les six jeunes
chacun donc maintenant qu'est ce qui se
passe déjà mal intentionnés ont autre
chose avec dans le temps était pour des
dirigeants pour s'ouvrir la famille est
la nôtre a pas de son vivant qui serait
pas conservé la famille ne meurent pas
je me rappelle j'étais venue de la nisa
avec deux piétons qui j'étais sur ma
tête de largement disait pendant la
récréation un lézard
les avec ta tête germes est il avait
début de q2 que du coup je gérais le
petit je me lève un tabou bien je ne
pouvais plus où la cour il rapidement
j'ai découvert là maintenant je ne peux
pas été là il a tenu ma tête la pensée
des paroles d'un 4 étoiles je crois que
j'ai tout donné sur le champ aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui se passe même déjà les
prêts qui lui c'est un d'énergie pour
faire du mal à leurs proches
je prends un autre exemple d'un collègue
qui a commencé par ça va être dans ce
groupe 5 de la place et il a fait son
action il est décédé
je crois qu'il a été inventé en groupe
et l'envoûtement aujourd'hui en afrique
que je crois que ça devient sérieux
des fois c'est le matin tu te d'où son
appel pendant et autour d'un poteau ou
de totem en évoquant non et on promet
pas prononcer des paroles incantatoires
et bien on tient le chien à la main on
coupe dans la gorge et le sang versé sur
le thème l'ayant nous pouvons sans nom
chose pour toi
non mais c'est pas fini ils avaient plus
à dire si ça vous intéresse vous
communiquez avec nous pour avoir ça m'a
fait un petit peu pas beaucoup un bon
coup et j'ai remarqué cela peut-être que
la prochaine histoire que qui se
trouvent sur notre site sur la page web
tam-tam canada va vous et paris
davantage parce que ça se passe au
canada dans l'eau est un continent
africain mais à ottawa la capitale
canadienne rien ça se passait parce
qu'on est dans une machine s'emballe
alors monté dans le temps ça se passait
il ya plusieurs mois de l'an dernier
un homme qui s'appelle moroz père et
s'est mis conservateur de l'exposition
du sud ouest de l'europe et de
l'amérique latine au musée canadien des
civilisations à ottawa un de nos grands
musées ici au canada est beau riche
assad l'a joint à nos collègues et pour
parler des 400 objets
vudu esque qui s'y trouve est emprunté à
une collection d'une experte en vous
d'où une histoire qui se raconte au
final en 3000 objets et en à peu près
une minute trente dont 90 secondes voici
il ya des pouilles il ya des poupées
dans le vaudou qui sont souvent accroché
suspendus à des arbres et qui servent
souvent à envoyer des messages aux
esprits des défunts aux ancêtres et mais
les vodouisants vont toujours vous dire
que normalement le vaudou n'est pas là
pour faire du mal aux gens
il est là pour soigner protéger les
aider à assa a surmonté des épreuves et
que s'il y a des gens qui peuvent
utiliser des pâtes au départ est ce
qu'ils peuvent utiliser le voulait
pouvoir de vaudou pour faire du mal à
quelqu'un d'autre il faut les considérer
comme des charlatans pour comme des gens
qui traînent détourne le vaudou de son
véritable objectif et il est tout de
suite après ils vont ajouter que de
toute façon cela ce tour se retrouve
dans beaucoup d'autres ritualité c'est
pas que dans le vaudou qu'on trouve ce
genre de personnes mal intentionnées si
je comprends bien il faudrait peut-être
écrire la chambre quand nuit pour lui
dire que le réalisateur avait tout faux
concernant la cérémonie vaudou est à
l'accueil pour les bars dancing seconde
ont détruit famille de complètement
d'ailleurs les commentaires qu'on les
visiteurs depuis l'ouverture de l'expo
là en novembre dernier
nourry jouer parce que la plupart du
temps les gens nous écrivent qu'il était
arrivé à l'exposition avec des idées
flou sur voo doo puiser dans les films
dans des ouvrages populaire sur tout et
que après les après la visite ils se
rendaient compte qu'elle vous d'où a été
vraiment une spiritualité avec une
vision du monde profondes riches chez
terra oui ça nous vrai que oui tout à
fait alors l'histoire s'appelle les
rites funéraires s'adapte aux
changements de la société québécoise
vous allez trouver 5 sur notre page web
attendant le canada cette semaine puis
évidemment parce que elle je pense que
quand vous étiez à l'école vous étiez
une élève pas tellement attentive parce
que l'écouté pas l'entrevue elle me
parlait de ce comment ça se passe dans
son monde aviez de la viande l'origine
vient du mexique
on dit que ça se passe aussi au canada
l'irlande a célébré dignement avant le
temps avant donc le 11 novembre ici au
canada ça se passe dans quelques jours à
peine
exactement ça a fait c'est aujourd'hui
même si on nous écoute à travers notre
site web c'est le 30 octobre en grande
fête des morts ici à montréal c'est la
fête organisée par plusieurs artistes
mexicains qui sont établis ici depuis
très longtemps
c'est une fête où il y aura de la
musique du théâtre déclin couleur puis
on va raconter un peu l'histoire est là
le respect qu'ils ont les mexicains pour
la mort qui ne le vois pas comme quelque
chose d'horrible ténébreux ou sombre
mais plutôt comme quelque chose des
bleus est ce une fête en fait c'est pas
une
c'est peu c'est une faille tout la fête
des morts je veux dire quoi on va
célébrer un symbole à faire une pause
radiophonique à dents sur les amis sur
internet c'est une pause radiophonique
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'internet
nous continuons ensemble mais pour la
radio on fait une pause musicale en
l'honneur de la fête des morts tel que
raconté par balles au mas martin hayes
alors notre histoire à faire peur et or
je trouvais ça cette fin de semaine je
travaillais pas les fins de semaine mais
j'écoutais mon écoute je travaille et on
veut pas l'admettre c'est pas bon là ça
pète
mais alors j'ai trouvé ça c'est un s'est
dégradée au canada international a
produit probablement il ya quatre ou
cinq ans peut-être ou plus que ça 6 7 1
très très bien fait avec 12 compte pas à
meyrin dit nécessairement mais douze
contes et légendes du canada et il y en
a une concernant une histoire de
fantômes qui se passe dans une érablière
au canada au printemps lorsqu'on fait
donc la collecte du de la sève d'érable
ou de l'eau d'érable pour la bouillir
dans des petites cabanes comme ça au
milieu de la forêt la nuit et qu'on est
seul dans la cabane je vous faire
entendre ça puis si vous voulez avoir la
suite les deux autres comptes
c'est au disponibles au modique somme de
119 heures et 14 ou non pendant les
prochaines semaines j'espère qu'on
pourra revenir sur cette affaire on en a
pas de céder que ça n'existe plus on a
que celui là voici donc une histoire de
fantômes dans une érablière
faire le sirop d'érable c'est tout un
travail
on doit faire bouillir la sève lentement
c'est pour ça que les acériculteurs
préféré passer ces longues semaines tout
seul par contre lorsque la nuit tombe et
il aurait bien aimé avoir de la
compagnie nuit baptiste riverains
étaient dans sa cabane à sucre quand
tout à coup il a entendu une plainte
venir de la cheminée
ça redore mais il ne voit aucune trace
dans la neige autour de la cabane à 6
quand il rentre il entend une autre fois
la planète
tout de suite après la plainte se
transforme en crise accompagnée d'un
gratte mans dans la cheminée baptiste se
sont vus en laissant son sirop bouillir
tout seul il traverse tout le bois et
rentre chez lui il passe toute la nuit
dans sa maison
il faut dire que notre baptiste n'avait
pas la conscience tranquille
son voisin philémon gamache lui avait
prêté de l'argent mais comme il était
mort pendant l'hiver bat us de penser
qu'il ne devait plus rien à personne
le lendemain matin avant de remonter à
sa cabane à sucre baptiste fait un petit
détour chez la veuve gamache pour payer
sa dette
de retour à la cabane à sucre baptiste
rallume le feu et recommencent à faire
son sirop à partir de ce jour là il ne
plus entendu aucun bruit
il est resté dans sa cabane pendant tout
le temps des sucres
puis quand l'assaillant arrêté de couler
des érables il le fait le ménage et
entasser les bidons sirop dans sa
charrette
juste avant de partir quand le fus a été
complètement éteint
il a démonté le tuyau de la cheminée et
savez vous ce qu'il a trouvé dans le
tuyau un gros éboue mantoue
alors vous la pauvre la polizia c'est un
conte pour enfants bien sûr mais ni ben
moi ouais ça doit pas ça très bon non
attendez une belle lettre qu'on a reçu
cette semaine et elle est vraiment là je
vous dis c'est toute une commande
les auditeurs ont le droit de nous ont
ordonné de faire des reportages sur des
sujets particuliers il n'y a pas des
patrons qui peut qui ont ce droit là et
ça me fait plaisir en une section web
ça s'appelle votre votre choix notre
promesse et c'est notre promesse de
répondre par des reportages des
entrevues à des questions spécifiques et
même si c'est une question à tiroirs
multiples comme celle ci a envoyé par
question look
en france il dit j'ai écouté l'émission
tam-tam canada du 23 octobre et le sujet
sous la détention des six migrants
illégaux canada pour ce fait j'ai
quelques questions à poser écoutez bien
stéphane qui les quais les week-ends et
les taux d'octroi aujourd'hui du statut
de réfugié au canada pour le demandeur
d'asile est ce qui en matière d'octroi
du statut du réfugié
le canada reste s'il parmi le bon élève
et généraux pays au niveau des pays
développés le canada accueille combien
de réfugiés par an sur son seul le
canada est-il généreux qu'elle offre et
telus ou si généreux que la france les
états unis le royaume uni l'australie ou
la nouvelle-zélande
en ce qui concerne l'octroi du statut de
réfugié je veux commencer à répondre à
100 on n'en finira plus mais on va le
faire
on a préparé quelque chose d'autant plus
qu'au mois de novembre le gouvernement
canadien va annoncer sa nouvelle cible
pour l' immigration canada
on devrait avoir plus de donner aussi
concernant le dossier des réfugiés d'un
accueil des réfugiés au pays donc une
bonne occasion pour nous de faire un
arrêt en gare et de répondre à des
questions comment faire pour obtenir un
emploi de chauffeur routier au canada en
questions envoyées par hamidou dembélé
qui habite en côte d'ivoire à
grand-bassam descend on adore ça quand
vous préciser d'où vous écrivez parce
que vous savez l'internet c'est
tellement tellement impersonnel mais au
moins il va quand on a des goûts gagnent
un peu plus on sait que c'est on peut
diriger la question de telle façon la
réponse de telle façon telle façon parce
que véritablement lui voudrait trouver
un emploi dans ce domaine pour rappeler
que
en botte camionneur est le plus
populaire au canada c'est celui qui en
pole plus de personnes ça tourne autour
des 3% de la population active
canadienne qui est chauffeur chauffage
de camions qu'il savait pas bien moi non
plus on a déjà commencé à faire un peu
la recherche au niveau
maintenant notre meilleur de la semaine
en cent cinquante secondes le voici le
voilà c'est la danse d'aller retrouver
quelque chose sur lequel paloma a
travaillé on a trois reportages c'est le
meilleur de la semaine et un voyons voir
si vous allez devinez le sujet sur
lequel paloma a travaillé cette semaine
voici on écoute tous radio canada
international vous présentant 150
secondes
notre meilleur de la semaine d'abord
volé aux autochtones nord symbole et
s'approprier leur culture calmement la
récupération commerciale des symboles
traditionnels des arts visuels
autochtone se transforme-t-elle en
exploitation insensible insultante
s'il vous plaît respectez nous pasqua et
directrice des communications à
l'université des premières nations du
canada en saskatchewan
un coiffeur un tiers donc on a aussi en
anglais le prof de guerre avec des
belles plumes d'aigle on sait que pour
nous les aigles cdc des oiseaux sacré et
puis trop mérité une punaise
il ya tout en mai mais je les fous donc
si un coiffeur ndiaye coiffe abonnés de
guerre c'est avec combien de plumes
temps c'est tout un grand de
reconnaissance une personne si on va le
porter qui portait ça on perde tout
7en et noir les contextes l'historique
en et noir entre tuer des stéréotypes
puis si tout se déroule comme prévu le
jeune de québécois lance stroll fera son
entrée dans l'écurie williams pour la
saison 2010 est de la formule 1 aux
journalistes sportifs fils crépeau
suisse jean pilate depuis les tout
débuts
il a gagné des championnats de quartier
dès 2008 il avait donc dix ans il a
gagné le championnat du québec et gagné
le championnat canadien
donc il a fait ses classes il a fait ses
gammes au québec
il a en effet gagné en karting
championnat du québec championnat du
canada ça lui a permis de partir en
italie
faire du karting participer au
championnat du monde de karting qui est
chaque année en italie qui a terminé
cinquième du championnat du monde de
karting en 2012 ça lui a ouvert les
portes
enfin être adolescent au canada où l'on
compte près de 2 millions et demi de
jeunes âgés de 13 à 19 ans ces jeunes
ont des choses à apprendre aux autres
adolescents et adultes du monde entier à
commencer par la langue de l'amitié
voilà notre manière de la semaine en
cent cinquante secondes pour les
entrevues intégrale les articles qui les
accompagnent cliquez sur les hyperliens
déposé sur la page web de tam-tam doit
radio canada international
alors si tu veux avoir le détail de ces
entretiens
alors je bouge ou signale que vous allez
donc vous avez les vidéos sont page web
lorsque vous venez d'entendre c'est en
vidéo
magie des haies vous avez donc ces
communes c'est comme aller au restaurant
c'est la carte logement de la carte
aujourd'hui que ce soit cher qu'est ce
que je remette dedans maintenant mon
assiette et vous fait choisir ce que
vous voulez un pic est obligée là dedans
donc vous avez deviné le sujet de paloma
cette semaine elle répondait à une
question d'un autre star sur
l'adolescence au canada qu'est ce que
c'est que de laisser au canada comme
j'en suis plus éloignés probablement que
vous je suis content vous avez des
questions ou gérard que j'avoue que j'ai
pris d'assaut très tôt faisant pendant
que ça passe
merci seulement sur le web à la radio
c'est une toute autre histoire
maintenant on termine par le maillard
j'allais dire votre reportage pas tout à
fait le cas
nouvelle question de la semaine
c'est quand même oui alors voici notre
question de la semaine prochaine s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît de vous
tourner vers les gens sur leur facebook
me plaît s'il vous plaît
pouvez-vous répondre à cette jolie
question parce que tout le monde va
vouloir y répondre
vous pourriez le faire avant tous les
autres si vous vous mettez en action
maintenant voici la question caméra
qu'aimeriez-vous dire au sélecteur
américaines qui s'apprêtent à élire leur
nouveau président ou présidente
ce mardi 8 novembre quel message ça
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
avez-vous des messages aller voter ça va
ou gestes et ses mots ses lettres je
peux pas donner mon opinion tout à fait
on n'a pas besoin de donner notre vie à
aller voter c'est tellement important
voter c'est un droit
cette fois ci écoutez pas le bas ce fut
un charme également notre spécialiste
web n'était pas là cette semaine seul
qui est responsable du web francophone
anglophone et irradie bai yan m'a dit tu
te débrouilles et merci beaucoup à
leonardo leonardo de la section
espagnole qui ont le regard on se
tournait souvent lorsqu'on était à la
caméra ce qu'on lui parle et que vous de
venir faire un petit tour à la caméra
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
les gens qui écoutaient la radio oublier
ça vous pouvez pas le voir temple il est
là il nous a aidés tout là toutes les
missions je vous rappelle que s'ils
voulaient voir le facebook live
même si c'est diffusé à dre en retard
vous pouvez voir sur la page web de
tam-tam canada au fond retenu une chose
tout et sur la page web de femmes canada
ici stéphane parent à la semaine
prochaine ce n'est pas chez paloma
martinez sort